what's the formula for a bad story I
feel like there's many ways that a story
could go bad not picking the right
character to be the lead
I've definitely have read scripts where
the lead character is much less
interesting than like a secondary
character in the script it's like why
are you focus here being completely plot
driven to the point where we don't
really have characters well if the whole
story is just set these up there's that
piece we don't care about what's going
on or who the people are in the cool set
pieces they can be as cool that you want
and still kind of fail because there's
not enough of a story there you know not
not having any kind of connection I
think is probably the biggest the
biggest bad thing that you'll see in a
script is you know having the wrong
character or not caring about the
character I know that uh anti-heroes are
like a big thing nowadays you know like
the Joker movie and and Breaking Bad
series of you know and so a lot people
think you know because it used to be
that oh you have to like the character
well you don't necessarily have to like
the character know if anybody liked the
character in Joker there's something
wrong with them it's like if you can get
on board with that character doing those
awful things tribes are wrong with you
but the thing is you care about the
character right because you know they're
they're doing the bad things but like
you're seeing in addition to the bad
stuff you're seeing like the human side
of the character is showing there's
something that you can connect to you
know like taxi driver even which again
is a similar story to Joker and so
they're doing the bad stuff but like you
they've got humanistic things about them
you know that connects you we're in like
even superhero movies you know like
those quotes from some famous directors
that we won't throw under the bus you
know you know Oh superhero movie is you
know they're just like a roller coaster
ride or whatever he said it was it's
like but you know if like superhero
movies done well you care about the
character like that's the thing that
like Marvel does really well you know in
in their movies is that you care about
the superheroes it's not just this
guy in an iron suit we can blow stuff up
with you know repulsor cannons or
whatever it was called like you care
about him and his interactions with
other people around him and his you know
how he wants to solve the problem if it
was just a faceless person in a thing
blowing stuff up there's nothing there
to care about you know so that's
probably the biggest bad thing people do
is not giving us something to hold on to
for the character do you think that the
level of empathy has improved like I'm
forgive me I I don't know much about the
superhero era so I'm hoping you can
educate me on shore so let's take
Christopher Reeves as super Superman
okay all right yeah so do you think that
version of Superman has evolved in terms
of some of the humanistic qualities they
give to him um so like our if we like
we're to compare that one with like some
of the more recent Superman um I feel I
love okay I love Christopher iam
Superman I love Henry Cavill as Superman
they're fantastic but they're very
different Superman the movie is
obviously the tone is much darker in the
new one than the one in the 80s
different times yeah things in the world
but there's still in each of them they
still have human traits like they're
this alien from outer space who is
godlike powers but they were raised as a
person you know so they're not Superman
is his secret identity he's Clark Kent
if you think of the stuff because he was
raised by my own pocket to be a good
person
long before him and had the ability to
knock over buildings and you know carry
kryptonite planet there rocks mountains
into the space you know like like
happening because you know Superman
Returns you know Brandon Ralph's
Superman which is a continuation but oh
I can go into too much Superman stuff
but the point is they were people they
were humans and they were brought up as
good people from their parents before
they had the ability to do godlike
things you know so if they were just it
was just somebody who
was automatically born already had the
superpowers and because there are so in
comic books
one thing that DC used to do was the the
Elseworlds
stories and there's my favorite one is
Superman read son they're gonna have an
animated version of come out later this
year I'm psyched for it where he you
know crash-landed in Soviet Russia and
he was basically raised as the supermen
to the ubermensch you know so he makes
it became their weapon you know it
during like the the wars and stuff and
so it's it's a whole nurture versus
nature thing you know of how he was
raised because his his humanity is much
lower in red Sun than it ever was in the
main continuity because he was raised by
mom Paul Kent over here
where's over here he was you know raised
by you know soldiers and the government
and stuff like that to be a weapon I
don't know where I'm going with that I
think you you you've touched on it so
we're trying to it sounds like because
of the timing of so the a times that the
world was definitely a different place
yeah fears and there were things looming
but it seems like today the intensity
and then hence the story is darker yeah
so the tone is darker but it but he's
even if you look at him as a character
though he still got raised by mom and
paw kid so he still makes you know
humanistic choices even when he's
fighting against Assad you know one
thing that everybody in for the new
Superman movie with in Cabell the people
didn't like him in Man of Steel was that
he end up killing Zod at the end spoiler
alert if you didn't see it yeah they're
like oh no Superman would never kill but
that so it's a much dark thing but it's
he still made the choice to save human
life you know because that's the way he
was raised you know like his his own dad
you know made him not be Superman
basically to save other people and stuff
because it would out him well in this
case he is doing whatever it takes to
save those people because he couldn't
save people before so who and in going
back to the Christopher Reeve version
he's you know doing whatever it takes to
save the people like putting himself
in harm's way with like the kryptonite
and then having the scope missiles
granted in the old one he got the fly
around the earth to save Lois inversed
time which our guy didn't get to do but
uh he's still making all of his choices
based on a human quality as opposed to a
Superman in quality he's just a human
who gets to do the Superman quality
which is why I say that Superman it's
not that Clark Kent is not his superhero
@na Superman is Clark Kent secret
identity
you